i'm patrick bay david your host of
valuetainment weekly and today's
question is what is worse
making fun of people or assuming they're
too weak to take it
that's a pretty good question isn't it
but i didn't ask that question that
question is actually from
kian peel from comedy central who did an
article they were on the cover of time
magazine right
uh march 24 2014 the title is case for
mockery
uh and the question was you know what's
worse making fun of people are assuming
they're too weak
um to take it right and then they
continue and they say you know when did
america get so politically correct
it's when we refuse to mock a group of
people that we truly act like bullies or
another one of their comments here is
somewhere along the line
we've forgotten the true purpose of
humor
to help people cope with the fears and
horrors
of the world you know i think about
myself
we lived in iran war my family both
sides
they were all about humor jokes making
fun of each other and
telling all these funny jokes and we
really had to have thick skins right
and then and i think about myself there
was a period i couldn't stand when
people made fun of me you know as a kid
i don't know if you
like when people make fun of you but i
got a question for you here's a question
for you
you ever made fun of your parents before
if i give you a thousand dollars right
now
could you imitate your parents maybe
your father you know discipline where
maybe your mom could you imitate them
have you ever imitated your boss or the
person you work this is between us this
is not going anywhere this is just
us you ever made fun of your boss don't
you love making fun of your parents or
your boss or
you know brother or somebody you know
somebody just kind of mocked them every
once in a while
and is that a bad thing is that a bad
thing to do it's interesting when we
think was it a bad thing to do because
i remember when i first came to the
states you know there's a lot of mockery
or fun or some of these things and you
think about
can we fully control it by making
everybody be politically correct so they
don't say the wrong things and
you know you're too this and you too
then yes there are people that are a lot
more sensitive than
others and uh i've learned over time
that if i'm dealing with somebody that's
too sensitive just kind of don't
you know try not to make fun of them but
if i'm trying to shape somebody's
mindset i want to encourage them to kind
of be tough to be able to take it from
other people because if you don't
you're not going to move up in life the
more you move up the more challenges and
more people are going to make fun of you
so it's better if you can start making
fun of yourself instead of having other
people make fun of you
give you a few examples when i came to
the states my english wasn't terrible it
was horrendous is what it was so
i stayed esl for a long time a few words
you can have fun on me i couldn't say
the word government
yeah i thought americans were playing
tricks on us when they put the end there
why do we have an
end there it shouldn't say government so
i would say
today i'm taking my government class
right can you imagine government right
government right instead of government
right the show i used to watch all the
time was gilligan's island and i never
said gillian's island i would say
gilligan's island and all my peers would
laugh at me
while you're laughing it's not islam
it's ireland right or or
i remember they would say hey you're
you're uh you're a phobe
i say what's a folk you're fresh off the
boat what's fresh off the you just
came here fresh off the boat from iran
is what you are that's why you sound the
way you do my accent
and this kept going on whether it's the
word wednesday i used to say wednesday
right then i joined the army in the army
i meet people from oklahoma wyoming
south dakota north dakota you know all
these weird places i've never seen
before they've never met a middle
eastern before and they would say
look at me funny from the side and i
knew you know when somebody's looking at
you
but they don't want to kind of make the
eye contact and i would look at them say
what are you what are you looking at
they would say
can i ask you a question yes what's your
question
where is your turban i'm sorry
how come you don't have it aren't you
from iran i am from iran
where do you wear turbans i've never
worn a turban in my life before
oh okay is it true that you guys go to
school on camels
camels yeah i mean aren't you guys camel
jockeys
camo what what's a camel jockey like do
you think we had freeways where camels
are going on freeways spitting at each
other
what do you have i exit on this street
here with my camel this is what i'm
gonna be doing right
my goodness i've been called all the
words but here's what i learned here's
what i learned
i learned if you want to move up in life
in leadership positions you are going to
be made fun of
whether you like it or not because you
ain't perfect i'm not perfect
we're gonna make mistakes and people
love making fun of people making
mistakes i'm sorry but people love doing
it let me give you an example
i want you to watch this episode and
think about who the world makes the fun
of the most
very easy presidents let's start off
with will ferrell
doing a quick impersonation of president
george bush
when you think back to biblical times
when adam and eve
talked to that snake six thousand years
ago
when the world was created it was hot
back then too
why do you think adam and eve were naked
you see what i'm saying i mean i'm not
making this stuff
up why do you think adam and eve were
naked
is that amazing how how how many people
made fun of president bush and
every day no matter what channel you
were watching somebody was making fun of
president bush
here's here's one that i saw i thought
it was pretty interesting here's jimmy
fallon
and former republican presidential
candidate
romney doing a skit together
jimmy i'm not running again a lot of
great candidates for 2016 and i'll be
supporting the republican nominee
100 percent don't you mean
47 that's a low blow but it's pretty
funny i had to do it yeah yeah
do you remember when that statement of
47 was criticized
all over television and they're having
fun about it and people are laughing
about it all over the country
i think about this last one here with uh
zach uh
zach galifianakis try saying that five
times right galifianakis zach
galifianakis interviewing president
obama
so do you go to any websites that are
dot coms or dot nets or do you
mainly just stick with uh dot govs
no actually we uh go to.gov have you
heard of healthcare.gov
here we go okay let's get this out of
the way what did you come here to plug
well first of all i think it's fair to
say that i wouldn't be with you here
today if i didn't have something to plug
have you heard of the affordable care
act oh yeah i heard about that
that's the thing that doesn't work why
would you get the guy that created the
zune
to make your website you're talking
about making fun of the leader of the
free world i mean
it doesn't get worse than this and
they're able to take it president obama
handled it well so that romney and what
bush has fun with it right now when he
interviews all over the place
but i think about this you ever heard
imitation
is the highest form of flattery right
we've heard that one before
when people make fun of other people
it's pure respect it's pure flattery
you've made it you've done
something with your life where people
are wanting to imitate you
make fun of you it's a compliment but i
think
you know one of the most important
things is realize when you can start
having fun with yourself and laughing at
yourself with your weaknesses it doesn't
matter what other people
say about you because if you can laugh
at your own weaknesses
does it really matter what others are
going to say about you because you've
already accepted your weaknesses right
it's my message of the week to you and
please be sure to subscribe and share
this video
you